I've seen dudes talk about uh how Asians
shouldn't aren't allowed to do hip-hop
and they go and teach in Asia
and they'll go and teach in Switzerland
and say white people can't do hip-hop
and I'm like stop teaching them
[Music]
and welcome back everybody to another
amazing episode of the careful boys
where we have a careful girl here today
let's get up for Kristen y'all
cool last name what's the origin Italian
oh [ __ ] I should have known that spicy
let me get some extra Farina on this
pizza
we're just talking about how you can't
say the word [ __ ] anymore right Nick
no I think I think it's uh well Nick
loves that word but I feel like
everyone's saying it only gets mad
here's the point on that word it is
the medical term is mental retardation
so I feel like if it's used in the right
that is the medical term yeah yeah and
if it's not offensive you gotta put your
hands up everybody's doing it like this
be chilled out so the doctor tells you
hey you're mentally [ __ ] what does
that mean what do you mean the doctor
goes because the medical term right yes
the doctor goes looks like you're
mentally [ __ ]
how do you take that something tells me
he's not telling the person who's
[ __ ] oh here's how you relate it so
so you got you're smart if you cause if
you're like you're gay you can actually
be gay and be homosexual but you can
also use it
um and be like oh that's so gay so it
just depends on the way that you're
using yeah intention and context which
the world doesn't [ __ ] get any bar
[Laughter]
you can't use medical terms like like
what um another one is I think
hermaphrodite when you're it's like it's
called like intersex or something now
you can't say hermaphrodite I learned
hermaphrodite in biology when you have
both who says it who says that though
um
True Lies True Lies because some
creatures are actual hermaphrodites they
got both yeah What creatures like a
seahorse yeah like if there's a
population if there's too many uh
females then some of the females would
convert into males whoa oh and vice
versa there's a school of fishies like
that too when the when they're all uh
when they balance out their population
by like being like I know there's too
many girls in this room well don't worry
about that and then some of the girls
turn into Boys
what Happened on Jurassic Park when life
finds a way
nice nice I think earthworms are also
hermaphrodites something like that am I
allowed to say that I think that's why
you can't say it is because it it
misrepresents the culture that the
culture of earthworms well no but like
you know if it's not it's like calling
us Oriental it's like that's not right
that's still funny before I knew
Oriental was a bad thing I thought it
was so cool because my friend was a part
of this group called The Oriental bad
boys and I was like oh you Oriental bad
boy are you sure it was Oriental or the
bad boy part
no I mean
I think the descriptor is good yeah dude
if there was no negative word for
Oriental right I would rather be
Oriental than Asian because Asian just
sounds
Oriental it's like oh it's like Oreo I
love Oreos the sound is like the
association because a it sounds like it
is you know like orientals like Oreo
I love Oreos and lentils
I must like you Oreo lentils yeah I
don't know I mean that's like that's how
they came up with Google it's easy to
pronounce it
that's true that's true
that must be the thing it's like they're
trying to get rid of the negative
connotation but it's gonna keep changing
dude so do you think that there's like a
scientific term for it and then Society
takes it puts a negative connotation and
then they go oh [ __ ] we gotta change it
up now that's what happens all the time
with words yeah that's like that's like
when we use girl as an insult like oh
don't be such a girl you know and then
girls don't like that Mr Miyagi said
that yeah don't be okay or I guess I
guess in present day it's like a Karen
nowadays yeah now nobody's name anybody
can because that's like the wrong way it
was a name and then people put an
association and then people get offended
and it's [ __ ] up or how everybody
named their daughter like Daenerys and
then the season finale came out and
everyone's like [ __ ]
she's An ancestry no no what happened to
the finale I watched the finale but it
made me go I'm not even gonna go there
anymore Bart really
because he probably didn't feel that the
ending of Game of Thrones I thought I
thought Daenerys is a great name right
it wasn't like that no but then like the
Jon Snow and the Daenerys reveal
what about it now regardless of the no I
wanted him to [ __ ] no matter what yeah
yeah I wasn't mad at them [ __ ] which
isn't the point of this conversation it
was just more the idea of like her being
the hero but then actually heard not
being the hero by the end but you like
imagine you named your daughter after a
hero well that's what you get but then
at the end it's written that she's not
quiet that's your fault for naming the
mid-season that's what I'm saying I
didn't know Walter White was gonna be
like that yeah well he was like that in
the middle of the first season but he's
still there that guy I didn't know he
was gonna [ __ ] be a meth dealer he
seemed like a nice man in first he was
just a chemistry teacher in the
beginning it tells you that in the first
episode
yeah he's already running around his
underwear I didn't know that was a
premise uh it's kind of like the word
gay like that didn't originally mean
homosexual I meant Happy a lot of people
used it but now you say that you sound
gay yeah yeah there's Christmas songs
with gay in it yeah we're gonna have a
gale time
I was feeling gay and [ __ ] what was
the word we're all hap we're being
married yeah gay and married yeah let's
be hella gay I don't think they had
hella in the of the new versions Yeah
Christmas songs words do change all the
time like like there's like like words
that are profane and whatever and then
you you read them and you're like that
means nothing to me yeah like bloody
like they say that [ __ ] in the UK oh
bloody hell it's supposed to be a bad
word and I'm like no this means nothing
I like that and I'm like intent and
context means everything yeah because
like someone if they went like even like
looked you up and down you might as well
say [ __ ] you to me you know yeah that's
for Asian yeah me to hear the actual
[ __ ]
ing Sky despises me when people are
talking [ __ ] in their native tongue you
can kind of know that they're talking
[ __ ] but you're like yeah I don't care
what you're saying because I don't
understand it's true yeah yeah language
is a [ __ ] though like the idea of like
you were just saying that that when it's
in my mind right now like when somebody
goes like but it's like from their
culture it could mean something like
that right like the f word uh versus
like uh all the Chinese people that
always go like [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] you
know what I mean
um which please don't use that as a
sound bite you [ __ ] out there
um but the point is because it's like
what the [ __ ] did he just say knowing
that you can take like language put them
in the inappropriate context and turn it
into something that's like offensive or
abusive over like the period of time you
know and clear it up right now what does
that mean in Mandarin it really means
just like this like this uh this this
literally or that you're just saying the
word that's such a common word it's a
thinking word it's like us saying um um
um so when they are thinking they'll
[Laughter]
is like like that right so the idea of
like saying both of those words but then
you know we all grew up with like Jay-Z
songs too you know what I mean and it's
like he was speaking Chinese yeah he's
speaking Chinese all the time but he
gets that's why he's worldwide he's
famous that's why he's worldwide that's
what I thought was weird is when you
take the something that's not a good
word in one region and you force a total
foreign region to follow that I think
that's [ __ ] like when there was that
uh that one a little Korean girl was
like singing bounding the lyrics to Like
a song and it had Nega in it and she
said she was just saying and then all
these people flushed her social media
being like you can't say that yeah and
then she had to apologize for it was
just saying like a Korean song a Korean
yeah it was like or was it actually I
think it was a I guess a Chinese song
that had that word she was just singing
along to a Chinese song but like all
these people made it seem like she was
doing something bad and she got super
like anxiety from it because she didn't
know what she did did and then she ended
up issuing an apology and everybody was
like why you don't even know what you're
freaking saying sorry for like why would
you force that yeah that's the mob dude
I remember doing covid right there was
this there was this trend for Chinese
farmers who uh would show their cotton
field and then eat their watermelon
right and then they were like they were
like it was like a trend like a
challenge for them like they're like hey
look at my Harvest and I guess cotton
Farmers also like farmed watermelon too
and then they didn't know about that
whole racist stuff being in America so
Chinese Tick Tock was doing all this
stuff and then like I guess like black
Twitter got a hold of it and they're
like look at these guys they're so
[ __ ] racist and there was this whole
thing during lockdown where they were
just like [ __ ] these Chinese people
hating black people and I was just like
dude that has nothing to do with what's
happening in America that's like it's
just they don't even know both sides
don't understand saying yeah they're
just like hey look at look at my Harvest
we just need good watermelon okay
we just need good [ __ ] watermelon but
then there is that other dude that
[ __ ] Chinese guy that went to Africa
and started a channel where he does make
fun of Africans that that was what he
was so set that guy on fire yeah that
[ __ ] guy dude [ __ ] him yeah beat his
ass but keep the watermelon if you
understand common sense right that's you
can see the intent that guy's being a
[ __ ] dick versus a farmer that's like
hey look at what I grew right and then
it's like hey a lot of people grow
cotton it's like what are you talking
about you know I don't know it's a hot
commodity it's true I mean yeah it's not
it's not the culture we live in so it's
kind of funny to judge it overseas
this is not what we all do though yeah
it's because we're so [ __ ] bored and
we go against easy targets internet you
can hide behind the keyboard and say
whatever you want how do you guys feel
on on this there was this um Tick Tock
video some dancers in the community
um there's this girl she's white and she
had some African-American friends
um and they were doing like this little
dance and the songs you know it's a rap
song saying some stuff and people just
like started tearing her apart but she's
like dancing with her friends there was
no she wasn't trying to be offensive at
all what were they what were they
complaining about I don't know like the
song said monkey in it and they're like
doing like it was like a tick tock dance
that was really popular but she was with
her friends everyone was doing it um
she's obviously not racist
um you know she just has some friends
and people just started [ __ ] on her
like crazy I feel like it's so hard like
I don't even I don't even put any bad
words in my stuff because I don't want
it to be perceived the wrong way yeah I
mean she wasn't singing the song no she
was dancing to a song that already
exists yeah with her friends the dance
was already there
um so but people still she had to
apologize was she good at the dance
though yeah she's firing so I feel like
dances is going through that more now
than ever where it's like oh like you're
not you can't use hip-hop you're Asian
like you'll see that every now and then
you're like you [ __ ] kidding like
tell Michael Jai White to take his ghee
off yeah bro no more shuttlecon karate
it just sucks because none of the people
none of the people tell Bruce Leroy to
stop doing Kung Fu It's gotta go both
ways man you guys can't have comfort we
actually got a lot of [ __ ] for that
little kinjaz yeah kinja's got a lot of
uh [ __ ] for that doing the pandemic at
the at the rise of that how do you feel
about that just the idea tell Iverson a
stop playing for China then
undo everything
you want to have a divorce it's not it
shouldn't happen on any side because the
people who [ __ ] made hip-hop the
whole idea was that everyone could do it
so it's kind of [ __ ] weird that now
we're at this age and it's like people
are taking over and gatekeeping it all
of a sudden yeah gatekeeping is the
worst huh yeah let everyone enjoy it all
plus it's the thing that you have to you
have to be good at it and like what I
didn't think was fair is that like okay
I'm gonna start doing this thing that
was created by black communities and
then sustained by uh Puerto Rican
communities and it came all the way to
[ __ ] here I still have to beat those
guys I still have to be better than them
I still have to like win my way up I'm
not just doing it and now I [ __ ] get
paid so you battled against like you you
battle against Puerto Ricans you have to
gain respect like anything you battle
against everyone but that's the whole
specific people it's not it's not an
entry level thing where you can just
start doing it now you're the [ __ ]
king of it it's like yeah no at the same
time you have to earn respect little by
little but most of you suck people don't
give you [ __ ] but the people that are
saying this [ __ ] they weren't even alive
no these things got it's like the new
gen and that's trying to be hella walked
but they don't quite understand all of
the [ __ ] that went down during Civil
Rights and all that and then when they
talk about culture vulture [ __ ] like
they don't even know the difference
between appreciation and appropriation
and then like even if we're talking
about appropriation too like that's a
really difficult thing to objectively
Define yeah like we can kind of guess it
like yeah if someone's exploiting
something or like making a profit yeah I
could kind of see it but like it still
really extremely hard to Define what
that thing is exactly
like and I always give this example too
because like yeah I'm a Japanese dude
and if I opened up a Ramen Shop with no
experience people would think like oh
it's authentic and I can fool the public
but there are non-japanese that you know
dedicate their lives to a craft like
making sushi or Ramen or whatever right
and then they might want to open up
their restaurant and they're probably
way more authentic than I am but then
people will look at them and be like oh
look at this fraud look at this culture
vulture but he did way more due
diligence I just busted out some top
ramen packs and just [ __ ] boys
yeah and then maybe I don't even speak
Japanese but guess what hey they're
gonna believe me more than him yeah
because I can't say nothing to you yeah
so who's the right one I don't know I
think you are I am I think you are
because I have birth right I don't think
there should be color lines between
anything that somebody made like what
what if Chinese people borrowed us from
using their Tech can you imagine how
much [ __ ] we can't do okay we couldn't
do this
no math for you yeah that's their Tech
nah but my number one thing about the
desk video and all a lot of the people
that are are supporting that [ __ ]
idea of who are they you I mean there's
no reason to put them out the only way I
want names is you gotta [ __ ] walk
into the room and go
they're like you act more [ __ ] Asian
like fine I'll be my own culture then
I'll [ __ ] walk into the room like
this I want to bring this back I've seen
dudes talk about uh how Asians shouldn't
aren't allowed to do hip-hop and they go
and teach in Asia
and they'll go and teach in Switzerland
and say white people can't do hip-hop
and I'm like stop teaching them well if
Asian people can't do it they got to
teach with them they gotta import it
from overseas well yeah at the end it
all comes down to money it's like you
know it really is just kind of like a a
really weird who you know double-edged
sword in terms of like perspective right
it's like I remember people might
randomly give us [ __ ] for like dancing
like Kendrick Lamar but also remember
like being super inspired the four
[ __ ] Chinese outfit exactly he was
kung fu Ken he did an entire creative
expression off of like Kung Fu and Asia
black people love Kung Fu they do and
they're good at it and wait but he hired
will never get mad at it we love it we
love it honestly it's sick the only
dudes I know that actively do kung fu
right now are all black dudes and the
Wu-Tang Clan owes us licensing fees and
we learned Kung Fu from two white guys
but
but we'll never win that argument in
America that's the craziest part you
know what I'm saying so it's like this
is what's crazy to me though like
when you're okay it's um in America that
[ __ ] is sensitive right when you're in
that country like for example Japan they
love it when tourists come and they put
on kimonos and put on the clothes and
eat the food because they're just like
oh they love our shoes they're like
they're giving us business right and I
made this like I was thinking about this
like with this whole like culture like
appropriation shaming [ __ ] it's actually
hurting a lot of communities and
businesses because if you think about
Chinatown right that used to be a
tourist spot where people that didn't
have enough money to go to China they
can experience the culture and they can
go to Chinatown and then what do people
do when they go there they buy The
Umbrellas they buy the like the the
outfit they buy the merch they buy the
merch but now you you don't see any any
white folks really buying the merch
because they're afraid that they're
gonna be like blamed or whatever and
then you see all these like little
Chinese grandmas desperate to [ __ ]
sell their [ __ ] and now the community is
like losing money right because like
like everyone's afraid to be racist and
[ __ ] yeah but Joe my culture is not your
prom dress that's what pisses me off
because these stupid [ __ ] and here's
the thing is most Asian Asians are not
going to town and buying all those
clothes anyway so but they're the ones
complaining hurting their own [ __ ]
communities and businesses and I'm like
this is the stupidest [ __ ] ever dude
like what about the folks that are out
there trying to create like jobs in that
community and you're hurting it because
now the tourism isn't coming there
so I'm like how do you I don't know it's
just stupid all I know is the top
selling Kung Fu song of all time is a
bunch of black dude that [ __ ] is dope
yeah and they love it and that gets me
hyped that they love kung fu you know
even when we were just talking about
Elon Musk and like verified Twitter and
stuff like that what is kind of cool
about in that connection is the idea
that uh less keyboard Warriors would be
around if everybody was verified too
right like because you wouldn't be
willing to talk [ __ ] or or be the person
on the front line if it was like an
actual person could be held accountable
as well yeah but when you're just a
[ __ ] digital account and nobody can
go back and Trace you and you if you
click their profile they're like a
private account or nobody follows them
it's kind of like of course you're a
keyboard Warrior you really can stand
behind a line of digital yeah most
keyboard Warriors are people with Burner
accounts they're cowards because they
can't show who they are they're afraid
exactly but like how many people would
do that if it was like their [ __ ]
actual digital profile and like where
they live and all that thing you know
what I mean it's like you wouldn't be
spreading hate as quickly there are some
people though that are verified and
famous that will still say the same
exact [ __ ] that is that is always up for
debate because like people are gonna
have opinions but but if you can at
least be like I'm still willing to say
this and this is who I am yeah I
actually respect that I would get credit
for a lot because it's like hey you're
willing to talk your [ __ ] you're willing
to criticize others you're you're
willing to stand behind your words and
people know who you are to me that's
even if I disagree with what they have
to say or what they're perpetuating I'm
like that takes a lot of guts like good
for you but when you're hiding behind a
burner account and you just want to
harass people talk [ __ ] do whatever is
I'm like you're a little [ __ ] like how
horrible is your life that you have to
do this that should just be disqualified
from the discussion every time totally
but then yeah when I did point out so
that video of that girl that was just
singing and was it super innocent and I
posted like a comment on there being
like yeah that's not fair to do and then
a bunch of like people try to make it an
anti-blm thing that I said that what and
I was like how I really didn't get it
and a lot of those people that were
talking [ __ ] to me were actually like
established verified people that were
like really pissed at the fact that I
was supporting that she it might have
just been momentum of that time too
right because like with those people for
sure say the same you know nowadays
especially after like all the BLM stuff
that went down you know what I mean like
I think everything is like contextual to
that the the fervor of society in that
moment even
blm's crazy because speaking of momentum
pre-2020 I always knew it as Bureau of
Land Management
and then all of a sudden
because if you're in the if you're in
like hunting and shooting an off-roading
Community you look for BLM all the time
you love BLM you want BLM to be
everywhere yeah because it just means
you can go into the white Wilderness and
go camp you do all these fun things with
BLM Bureau of Land Management now the
the new BLM is different than the BLM
Island which is land of all these fun
places and I'll build them's all like
grumpy and stuff
words changing
now I hear those three letters and it
feels grumpy it feels like they're mad
at you yeah you're like I don't even do
anything why are you mad I've been
supporting I'm on your team yeah did you
see like BLM members were suing BLM like
leaders because they burned like tens of
millions of dollars that the people were
donating and it didn't even go to the
families that they say that it was gonna
support or black organizations like it
just went to a lot of their friends
running like I mean lgbtq things and
then like that wasn't even gonna help
the black community and then like and
then like they they got audited and they
just bought a hell of mansions and stuff
like that in white neighborhoods yeah in
white neighborhoods that they're afraid
to live amongst it's funny because
that's that's no different like welcome
to the land of nonprofit corruption
that's everything yeah non-profit yeah
like you become a non-profit it's gonna
happen especially with the money that
they made so stop being a dick
that's true
[Music]